[Music]
top that Frank I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation it's funny a while
ago we had John Rendon who gave a talk a
year ago and everybody assumed he was a
conservative because he was doing work
for the White House well he's done work
for the last five White House's and
probably will do work for the next five
and he was a hard over Democrat
basically born that way and will stay
that way Frank is my favorite kind of
conservative I used to know Herman Kahn
and Herman was wonderful Frank is
wonderful
and one of the reasons Frank is
wonderful is unlike many intellectuals
he will stand up and be accountable for
stuff he's said and thought and revisit
it and engage in what's called
intellectual honesty Frank Fukuyama
[Applause]
oh thanks very much sir and I'm really
grateful to the long now foundation for
bringing me out here I was actually
supposed to have given a lecture in
November but I had a little accident on
my bike but I'm back on my feet and
really glad to be here when Stuart first
asked me to speak in this series he said
this is a series on long-term thinking
and can you talk about anything and I
thought and you know most of what I do
is pretty a policy oriented towards the
next six months to two years I'll
probably not then it occurred to me I'd
written this book while ago called the
end of history in the last man and I
thought well actually that does fit in
to the overall framework of this series
pretty well and I have been thinking
about this consistently ever since I
wrote the original article with that
title 17 years ago so maybe maybe we
could talk about that so that's what I'm
going to speak to you about today so
what I'm going to do is first since
there's been a lot of misunderstanding
about this I'm just going to restate
what the end of history was all about
and then I'm going to go through four
different objections every conceivable
objection to this theory has been raised
by one person at some point over the
years but I want to deal with the ones
that I believe are the most cogent and
quite honestly they're ones that I don't
necessarily have answers to and for all
I know the theory could be complete bunk
and will be disproven and in fact I'll
I'll give you several empirical tests
for whether the theory is is correct or
whether you'll be able to see that it's
correct as we go through as we go
through the lecture and the four just to
give you a little heads up the four
objections first has to do with radical
Islam and it's rejection of modernity
second has to do with the lack of
collective action and accountability and
basically democracy at an international
level the third has to do with the
problem of poverty about how you get on
the modernization escalator and then
fourth has to do with technology now let
me go to the question of what the end of
history was about in about ten days I'm
going to get on an airplane I'm going to
go to Japan to give a couple of lectures
and then after about ten days in Japan
I'm going to fly down and spend a couple
of weeks in the Highlands of Papua New
Guinea now between Japan and Papua New
Guinea you basically get the two ends of
the development spectrum at least as it
exists in today's world from a society
in the highlands where you actually have
certain pockets or tribes that have not
seen the next tribe over in PNG much
less a European or an Australian or a
Japanese or anyone else it was a society
that was completely a cephalus there was
no state and many of the people in the
highlands were are still basically
living at a hunter-gatherer level of
existence and then of course Japan is
Japan so the question is there was a
certain period in human history when
virtually the whole of the world looked
like Papua New Guinea everybody was
divided up into these little groups of
5060 people very isolated without
technology to produce agriculture
without higher forms of political
organization today increasing parts of
the world look like Japan China the
largest country in the world is hurtling
in that direction and the question that
this raises is is this a coherent
process and is there a reason to think
that the kind of modernization that
takes you from the level of Papua New
Guinea to the level of Japan is actually
driven by deeper social economic
historical forces or is it all just a
big accident could we all return to the
status of being Highlanders at some
point in in the future and is there any
particular reason to think that the
kinds of political systems we see around
us
have a have this kind of deeper
historical meaning now this is basically
a theory about modernization I guess
that's the simplest way to explain it
and of course modernization is something
that virtually every intellectual
believed in over the past I would say a
hundred and fifty years and in fact in
the years prior to the 1980s a large
majority I would say of progressive
intellectuals believed not only that
there would be a progressive
modernization as human societies evolved
but that there was also an end of
history in the end of history would be
some form of communist utopia and when I
wrote my original article in 1989 I made
a very simple observation which was that
I too liked all of the Marxists believed
that there was this progressive history
that was propelling societies to
different and more complex levels of
social organization but that it didn't
look like we're ever going to get to
communism that whatever seemed to be at
the terminal point of this modernization
process was some version of a
market-based economy and some version of
liberal democracy and so it was actually
a fairly modest thesis that we'd be
getting off this train one stop earlier
than most people had anticipated and so
it was not an outlandish thesis in terms
of the way that people have thought
about human history but it did seem to
reflect to me what were the big
developments at that time now in terms
of universal histories of which Marxism
is a variant there have been a lot of
them written in history a lot of them
are Christian because the Christian
Bible actually talks about a beginning
of history in the Garden of Eden or the
creation story and it talks about an end
of history you plan God's kingdom
arrives and in a certain sense of
Marxism was a secular version it really
in a sense took Hegel to say that what
you have in the human historical process
is something like the story of the
Christian Bible except played out in
increasingly secular terms and that was
a story that then marks continued you
can actually enlarge the story because
the kind of human history that I am
going to talk about has not been in
existence for more than about 10,000
years Bob Wright wrote a book a few
years ago called non zero in which he
actually tried to place all of human
history in a history of the biosphere in
general in which he noted that there was
this very long term over the course of
billions of years an evolution as you
went from prokaryotes to eukaryotes to
multicellular organisms where individual
single-celled organisms learn to live
with each other and cooperate in
multicellular beings and then so on up
the evolutionary chain I'm not going to
I'm not going to get into that part of
the story but it is possible if you take
a sufficiently long perspective as I
guess we're supposed to do in the series
to see that actually human evolution and
the evolution of human societies does
take place in a much broader
evolutionary story that includes
nonhumans as well now the main person
who has raised a systematic objection to
my version of the end of history my
version of modernisation that is to say
that there is a universal process of
modernization that sooner or later most
societies will arrive at is actually my
former teacher and still a friend a good
friend Samuel Huntington who wrote a
book a few years after the end of
history called the clash of
civilizations and he made a very
different kind of argument he said that
the evolution of human societies in the
direction of liberal democracy was a
kind of accident that culture is the
ultimate way that this societies to find
themselves that there will be seven or
eight major cultural groups that will be
largely
in variant and that what I see as a
universal set of values potentially
universal set of values and institutions
that were developed in the West are
actually the cultural emanation of the
particular Christian culture that
happened to develop in this particular
part of Northern Europe at a particular
historical time but that if you grew up
in a Hindu or a Confucian or an Orthodox
Christian or Muslim cultural context
there is no particular reason to think
that you will develop similar sorts of
political institutions and so in a sense
his view is that all of the developments
that we have experienced in modernizing
societies is really culture bound and
that ultimately you can be modern you
can have an Islamic Republic of Iran
that could presumably produce
semiconductors and and you know very
high quality cars and yet be ruled by a
system of mullahs where authority comes
out of the Quran because culture is as I
said the ultimate defining
characteristic of societies that will
not be overcome by the integrating
forces of modernization now I have a
interlinked series of arguments about
why if you step back a little bit and
take this long perspective why should we
think that history is directional as
opposed to being simply cyclical or just
random you know one damn thing after
another and I would say that the
probably the one social phenomenon that
guarantees that you're not going to have
a random or a cyclical history is the
accumulation of knowledge related to
modern science and technology because if
you think about social phenomena the one
thing that is cumulative and is not
something subject to periodic loss
unlike let's say the arts or literature
or even particular forms of government
is the study of
emulation of knowledge that is driven by
human curiosity and human desire to be
able to master and manipulate the
external world now I would say that at
one end of this machine that I would
construct you would put the development
of science and technology as the driver
and it's connected by a drive shaft to
economic development because economic
development is determined by the horizon
of technological possibilities made
possible by any given level of
technological development so the world
of coal and steel or the steam engine
produces societies that look a certain
way you start urbanizing you start
developing an industrial working class
you have highly centralized larger
states but that is very different from
the kind of world that emerges after the
microprocessor after the internet in
which power tends to be more diffuse in
which it is much more difficult for
centralized hierarchies to control the
flow of information the flow of power
the flow of resources and therefore each
one of these economic ages is going to
differ in systematic ways from the one
that preceded it determined by the level
of technology and I think that is fairly
well accepted the process of
industrialization as you go from
resource exports to light manufacturing
to heavy manufacturing to full
industrialization and then to a
post-industrial society that's a pattern
that's been replicated by late
developers whatever the cultural
starting point from which they start off
now so the the the engine of Science and
Technology
you have economics and then there's a
much more loose set of connecting rods
that tie the economy to politics it is
the case that there is a very strong
empirical correlation between high
levels of economic development and
liberal democracy now
Huntington would say that this is simply
accidental that it just so happens that
the Christian West modernized first and
therefore this correlation between
wealth and democracy is a byproduct of
this this cultural phenomenon but it is
still striking that even outside of
Western the bounds of what we call
Western society including countries in
Asia this very interesting pattern has
emerged where at about six thousand
dollars per capita income which is about
the level that Taiwan and Korea achieved
sometime in the early 1980s you get the
development of an industrial working
class urbanization much higher levels of
education Universal literacy development
of a professional class a complex civil
society and the development of a
property property middle-class or middle
class to define in terms of its
ownership of property and all of these
things have been linked in various ways
to the emergence of political demands
for participation in systems there's no
question that you can have authority
Rhian modernization at very rapid rates
this is what South Korea Singapore China
today have all done but at a certain
level of wealth it seems that there's a
change in the nature of the society that
seems to demand greater involvement and
accountability in the way that
governments function which is what we
call political democracy so so the first
two parts of the machine are connected
fairly rigidly but the second part is a
pretty wobbly connection there are very
rich societies like Singapore that
aren't democracies and there are
relatively poor societies like Costa
Rica or India that that that are
democracy so it's not a perfect
correlation now at the far end of this
machine you get I don't know things
connected by strings or something
because when you get to the realm of
culture I actually agree with Huntington
that the the connections are not that
great I believe that ultimately you are
not going to get a homogeneous ation of
cultures around the world in
I would hope that we do not get a
homogenous Asian of cultures but there
probably is something in the boundaries
of cultural evolution that that needs to
take place in a in a really modern
society one of them may be secular
politics because among other things it
doesn't seem like it's very safe when
religion enters politics in a big way or
when you get politicized religion but I
think it's probably safe to say that at
the end of this train of gears or
whatever they are that that cultural
homogeneous we're never going to become
what what Huntington calls Davos man you
know this global cosmopolitan globalized
technology using consumer you know
self-satisfied consumer thank thank
goodness but the rest of the you know
the rest of the process it does seem to
me you can make an argument that there
is this kind of set of connections and
the question is whether the institutions
that we see in currently modern
societies are actually you know there's
no question that Huntington is right
that this stuff appeared in the
Christian West for reasons having to do
with a particular set of cultural and
historical events that took place in
early modern Europe democracy universal
human rights is in a way as many
philosophers Tocqueville Hegel Nietzsche
have all said it is a form of
secularized Christianity our doctrine
contemporary doctrine of human rights
comes ultimately from the Christian
doctrine of the universal equality of
human beings under God based on their
possession of certain divine attributes
like choice all right so there's no
question that historically there was
this connection but the question is once
you discover these institutions do they
become functional in a way that they are
usable by any other civilization
regardless of its cultural starting
points the scientific method was
invented by Rene Descartes
and and others in Europe at a certain
historical point but once it's
discovered it's invariant whether you're
African or Asian or Latin American the
scientific method becomes a kind of
universal possession and so the question
is our liberal democratic institutions
market institutions in the economy like
that or are they as Huntington would
argue culturally culturally bound and I
believe that even with all of the
sometimes terrible political events that
have happened since I first wrote this
article back in 1989 right as the Berlin
Wall was coming down that that basic
story about modernization is still on
track it is very fashionable I don't
know maybe it's different here in San
Francisco and Washington is very
fashionably that's pessimistic about
everything and a lot of people like the
intelligence agencies are paid to be
pessimistic and so you focus on
terrorism in the Middle East but we are
actually today and over the past five
years have been living through one of
the most remarkable periods in global
human history where there's not a single
region of the world that has not been
experiencing sustained growth and the
two largest countries in the world China
and India are leading the pack in terms
of growth rates now obviously there are
downsides to this global warming and all
sorts of you know perhaps unsustainable
trends that we've started but in terms
of people being lifted out of poverty
you've had several hundred million in
that category over the past 20 to 25
years because modernization has been
very successful in many many parts of
the world and so I think the basic
storyline of human development is still
very much with modernization the
question is does that modernization then
require liberal democracy or not and
here you've got these really two
interesting social experiments going on
which are Russia and China because
Russia and China are both modernizing
growing economically but under
basically under authoritarian regimes I
mean in Russia
you got a elections but basically no
horizontal accountability in the
political system and in China you got a
fully authoritarian system that
suppresses dissidents censors the
internet does all of these other sorts
of things so I told you I would give you
a way of testing whether I'm right or
not so one easy test is all you have to
do is wait 20 years and then you can
write to me but I'll be run hopefully
I'll be around 20 years you can say you
know has which of these systems has
democratic modernization at a lower
level like India or the high level like
Europe in the United States and Japan
has that proved to be politically stable
and successful and economically you know
productive or do these authoritarian
modernizers prove to have certain
long-term advantages I will make the bet
on the side of the liberal democracies
because I believe that modern political
systems have to be accountable you
cannot have good government without
feedback loops built into the political
system and as societies become more
complex as they do more things and as
government's do more things those
feedback loops those accountability
mechanisms become more and more
difficult so that if people cannot
protest the fact that a chemical factory
is dumping very toxic chemicals into the
a Moore River as happened in Harbin a
couple of years ago you are going to
have a less successful society than one
in which those kinds of accountability
mechanisms exist but it's a test and I
you know I'm no prophet so we'll have to
see how those experiments work out now
let me go through the four objections to
the theory I mean in a way the existence
of China and Russia constitute in
themselves a kind of objection but let
me go through the other one so let's
begin with Islam or not the religion
Islam but but the phenomenon that we've
seen particularly since September 11th
of a very radicalized Islamist ideology
many
people have said openly this is a
refutation of the end of history radical
Islamist Osama bin Laden the al-qaeda
folks do not want modernization in any
way shape or form not only don't they
want liberal democracy they don't want a
modern consumer society and so they are
very determinedly stuck in the Middle
Ages now I have always felt even after
September 11th that this is actually
giving these groups too much credit
because in fact with the one complicated
exception of if Iran certainly none of
the Sunni groups have succeeded in
coming to power in a single country and
in those places where they have
succeeded of Saudi Arabia Afghanistan
Iran this is not for anybody else that
is not an alienated Muslim living at the
fringes of a Muslim society these are
not successful models of development
that other people around the world want
to emulate and the desire to promote
this kind of political Islam really does
not you know it's not something that's
typically felt by people that are not
culturally Muslim to begin with now
the deeper question has been raised by a
lot of scholars is whether there are
permanent cultural obstacles to
modernization either in the economic or
in the political form and that somehow
this one particular cultural group
represents a particularly severe
obstacle my general view of that is it's
extremely unlikely that this is true
that there is really as far as I can see
no inherent reason in the religion
itself Islam to think that in a Muslim
society cannot modernize economically
and in fact you've had several fairly
successful cases of that like Turkey and
Malaysia or Indonesia at a lower level
of development and I also think there's
no particular reason why a Muslim
society cannot sustain create and
sustain a liberal democracy and again
you've got a number of
apples again Turkey Mali Senegal
Indonesia since 1997 so the question is
really what is the radical rejection of
modernity being driven by and here I
would say it comes less out of the
religion Islam percent because the rich
Islam is a religion it's very legalistic
it's very rooted in local traditions and
customs that define and describe to
individuals their particular identities
but what's very interesting about the
people in the contemporary world that
tend to be attracted to these Islamists
or jihadist groups is that they actually
are not people living in traditional
Islamist Islamic societies they are
people living at the fringes of Western
societies sometimes that's the case when
they live in Western Europe in Muslim
minority communities as was the case of
Mohammed hata or Mohammed we re who was
killed a Dutch filmmaker Theo van Gogh
or the July 7th subway bombers in London
sometimes the alienation comes when the
modern world comes to visit people in
the Middle East in the form of internet
television you know the Western cultural
onslaught that we associate with
globalization and I would argue that the
extremism you see is actually the result
of actually what is a fairly familiar
loss of identity for people that are
caught in this cultural no-man's land
between traditional societies and
successfully modernizing societies it's
quite interesting that successfully
modernizing societies like India and
China do not produce this kind of
terrorists but they really come more out
of a stratum of people that have been
exposed modernization but have not
gotten on the train
successfully and this actually I think
makes the phenomenon something it's not
that it should make you feel good about
it but it's something we've seen before
because that was the classic
sociological explanations
for the social origins of both fascism
and Bolshevism that typical Bolshevik or
fascist was a working-class person who
did not find a home in the
industrialized world just left the
village the tightly woven community now
living in a big city without a clear
identity Hitler comes along and says
I'll tell you who you are you are a
German and I think Osama bin Laden in
many ways has been doing that he says
I'll tell you who you are you're a
member of this global Muslim Ummah and I
can define your identity very precisely
in terms of the following ideology so
that doesn't mean that we are not going
to have a lot of big problems dealing
with this political movement now but I
just do not think that this is you know
rises to the level of a civilizational
challenge second big objection to my
theory has to do with the problem of
international society and democracy at
an international level now we have these
things called nation-state democracies
United States France Japan South Korea
so forth and actually after a couple
hundred years of political development
we pretty much know you know there's a
lot of variance but we pretty much know
what the institutions of a modern
liberal democracy ought to look like
what we really do not have in the
contemporary world are mechanisms that
enforce a certain degree of
accountability and reciprocity at and
and you know and that's another word for
democracy at an international level and
one of the things I think that's been
quite striking just traveling around the
world after the Iraq war is the degree
to which this has been exacerbated by
the overwhelming dominance of the United
States at a whole variety of levels the
United States today spends as much on
its military as the entire rest of the
world combined you know the British at
the height of their empire tried to size
their Navy so would be as large as a
second in the third next second and
third largest navies and we beat
everybody combines and that hegemony is
true at a political level we can
overturn regimes 8000 miles away we can
in in economics the dollar carry
continues to carry very great weight and
culturally the United States is very
hegemonic but it sets up the ground for
a huge amount of anti-americanism in the
world I think ultimately because of this
lack of both American what what
non-americans regard as American
accountability and the lack of
mechanisms of reciprocity I don't know
how many non Americans I've heard say in
the last few years you know I really
wish I could vote in an American
election because who you elect as
president has a big effect on my life
but American presidents are only
accountable to American voters and so I
think there is a kind of institutional
problem there institutional problem by
the way that I do not believe is ever
going to be solved by the United Nations
I think it's going to be solved by
actually a layering of multiple and
overlapping international institutions
many of which will not look like
traditional international organizations
that I believe you know simply have to
populate the world is one of the
consequences of globalization because
globalization does create winners and
losers and if you're going to keep the
world stable at an international level
those kinds of mechanisms of
accountability you have to be there so
that is a task I don't know whether
it'll be accomplished but I think it's
it's a task that's crying out to be done
third objection has to do with poverty
and the question of how you get on this
economic escalator to begin with I
mentioned earlier that the correlation
between a relatively high level of
economic development and liberal
democracy is you know as far as you know
I'm just a social scientist I'm not a
natural scientist but as far as we
social scientists code almost qualifies
as a law that these two things are
are pretty well are pretty well linked
but that presupposes that you can
somehow get yourself up to the level of
$6,000 per capita and it turns out that
that is actually not that easy for many
societies and there's a big chicken and
egg problem here the problem with
development I think is really not the
question of resources it's not needing
an external big push ala Jeffrey Sachs
it is a question of institutions you
cannot have long-term economic growth
unless you have a state and unless that
state can do things that states are
supposed to do like provide public
services and public goods maintain a
basic rule of law domestic order defense
from enemies and the like and I think if
you look around the world today you'll
see that those parts that have
successfully developed had relatively
strong states in their pre-modern
periods and it was only a matter of
getting the policies right that then
allowed them to take off so the state in
many respects in China was more ancient
than it was in Europe you go all the way
back you know three and four centuries
and you still had things that look like
centralized administrative apparatus 'iz
with bureaucrats and Taxation and
cadastral surveys and all those sorts of
things that states states undertake and
so it actually wasn't that big a leap
for a relatively strong state like China
to figure out that communism was a kind
of stupid economic policy replace it
with one that listened to market signals
and then they take off like like
gangbusters but in many parts of the
world including where I'm going Papua
New Guinea and including many parts of
sub-saharan Africa there was not a prior
tradition of stateless there were in
certain parts of Africa but in many
other parts of the developing world you
had institutions that were at a lower
level of development than than anything
that we would call a state and in many
other parts of the world what
institutions you had were severely
disrupted by colonialism
and I think you know the case of this
was was clearly the worst in Africa
where you had a whole variety of
traditional institutions at the time of
European colonization in the and
colonization came very late there in the
1870s and 1880s and the Europeans
basically by the time they got to Africa
didn't want to give them real
institutions because they wanted you
know they're kind of exhausted they were
looking at each other
wearily in the decades prior to the
Great War and they wanted to do
colonialism on the cheap so instead of
what the British did in India which was
spending a 200 year period
building in Indian institutions they
tried to empower local elites they did
various variations on local law local
rule that managed to undermine
traditional institutions without
transmitting anything like modern state
institutions and I think that this is
one of the big problems in global
development right now you cannot solve
the poverty problem and get people on
this escalator that will get you up to
this six thousand dollar level without
being able to solve this prior question
of having a state and having a political
order that can provide these sorts of
basic services I would go further than
that and say that there is actually an
important degree to which the current
international system actually promotes
state weakness in a whole variety of
ways sometimes we kill countries by
kindness about eight to twelve percent
of the GDP of every sub-saharan African
country actually comes from the
international donor community so it's
not lack of generosity I think that's
the problem but what happens is that
when you transfer money on those levels
you also infantilize countries because
they actually don't need to create their
own institutions they can rely on NGOs
and external donors to do this a lot of
cases we freeze conflicts Europe went
through in its historical evolution to
its current 20th century stage it went
through actually three separate stages
of evolution there
stage of state formation which is a
bloody period European rulers fought
each other to create territorially
coherent spaces political spaces a lot
of that required basically ethnic
cleansing to make sure that they were
relatively homogeneous a process that
really continued up through the late
20th century he excuse me second stage
was the implementation of a liberal rule
of law that restrained the sovereign and
then finally and only at the end you had
democratization and that process that
took 500 years in the case of a country
like France we are expecting developing
countries to replicate within a
generation excuse me and so for that
reason the problem of poverty remains
well I've been fighting a cold for the
last week my voice may be giving out
fortunately we're at the fourth point
now
last point is technology as I said the
historical process is driven by the
unfolding of modern science and
technology up till now
Tecna excuse me technology has been able
to solve the problems that it's set for
itself particularly the problem of
economic productivity there's no
particular reason to think that this
will continue forever and we have
certain technological developments that
could obviously end modernization
tomorrow the one that we've been
particularly particularly worried about
is is the question of global warming but
there are others as well there's been a
democratization of military technology
the whole problem of weapons of mass
destruction democratizes extremely
powerful means of destruction that used
to be only in the possession of nation
states now individuals potentially can
employ it and there are other issues as
well the ability to shape human behavior
in very subtle ways through
biotechnology is another issue that I
have written about in the future and
there's no guarantee that our political
institutions will keep up with this pace
of technological development you just
look at the collective action problems
that are engendered by dealing with
global warming and you see some
dimensions of that problem and on this
fourth point I give you no particular
assurance I cannot predict whether the
growth of the institution's at an
international level will meet these
requirements or not and if they don't I
think that the technology itself that
has been the source
of this broader story that I've been
telling you about modernization may
bring all of that to an end now I just
want to end by saying the following I
have been accused of being a kind of
Marxist
and of course the end of history was a
Marxist concept and as I said I was just
getting off one station early but I
think that I am quite different from
most Marx's in the sense that I do not
believe that there are iron laws of
history I do not believe that any of the
forces that I have described that would
tend to create a long term process of
modernization or a universal history as
I described it Locke societies in agency
individual human agency is extremely
important if particular battles had not
been one if particular politicians had
not gotten elected or had not taken
power in a coup d'etat the entire
subsequent history of those societies
could be written very differently I
believe as does Bob right that in the
end there are certain équilibre ting
mechanisms in human societies so that if
an invention is invented in one society
and then squelched as the as the rifle
was in early Tokugawa Japan it
eventually will get out because it
confers an advantage and there will be a
process of defensive competition as
societies interact with each other that
means that none of these inventions can
ever be suppressed for terribly long but
it doesn't mean that in the meantime you
can't have tremendous variation simply
based on the kinds of political choices
that we as citizens or we as politicians
or we as government officials make so
the fact that I still believe that
there's such a thing as history does not
relieve any of us from our
responsibilities as individuals to be
political participants because we
in very important ways can continue to
shape our political futures I'm not
going to take any more risks with my
voice completely going out so maybe I'll
just stop there and we can just take
questions but thank you very much for
your attention
[Music]
take a long drink in a long breath there
thank you Frank ah from Dan there's a
question in red ink raise your hand if
you're Dan with a red ink do you believe
in Jared Diamond's collapsed scenario
could happen on a global scale and I
would ask while we're talking about
Diamond he got his start on the Guns
Germs and Steel thesis in Papua New
Guinea that's right they were saying
that how come you know I'm carrying your
stuff well yeah I've got a lot to say
about that first of all as I just said I
think that you could have a
civilizational collapse for very
straightforward reasons I mean if some
of the more dire predictions about
global warming are true we'd probably
it's probably too late to do anything
about it and you know we could cook
ourselves and you know they're there so
there are various ways that that could
happen I think though that his you know
so it's it's a good warning on a general
level I do think however that there is
probably more robustness built into
human societies than then collapse
suggests I reviewed that book actually
and I was struck by the fact that you
know half of his cases took place in
these extraordinarily marginal
environmental niches where human beings
were probably never designed you know
destined to live in any event and so the
fact that they all died out of these
little islands in the South Pacific that
really couldn't sustain you know
vegetable life of any sort you know is
probably not a big accident there's a
much more important issue with regard to
development that he raises in Guns Germs
and Steel which is that he's basically a
materialist determinist in a sense I
mean that was the big thrust of that
book that most people looking in
development would say well it's
institutions its culture its you know
politics and so forth and you said no no
that's not right it's the material
endowments the disease burdens the
mineral resources other you know sorts
of things that countries were given not
as a result of their own choice but
but by nature and this is actually among
development economists led to a big
argument because Jeff Sachs among others
has taken this up and argued that you
know the real reasons for the lack of
development in places like Africa is
essentially you know disease burdens
malaria and things that are really
beyond the control of the particular
societies and that institutions are
simply a function of getting richer and
there's another school which I actually
adhere to that says it's the other way
around that you can create modern
societies in very inauspicious places
you know Singapore is in the tropics if
you have the right kinds of institutions
and without boring you with that whole
argument I I think that in a way the the
collapse book began to recognize the
importance of some of these non material
factors in development to much greater
extent than the you know then the first
one did which I think was a that was an
important change I get the sense you
take global warming more seriously than
you're used to
I I I never didn't take it seriously and
it seems to me that even if you think
that it's not you know the science isn't
there it's still a matter of risk you
know and and given the consequences of
betting wrong on this you know it
probably pays to hedge so I don't know
what the problem is so you've been
looking at Islam because it's one of the
four questions raised about your thesis
do you think that Islam can have a
basically what amounts to the equivalent
of the Protestant Reformation in a
period of time that will be part of your
20 year time frame
well not the 20 year time frame I would
suspect there's a very interesting
parallel between radical Islamism and
the Protestant Reformation there's a
French Islamist Olivier law who wrote a
book about three years ago called
globalized Islam that made this very
interesting case that he said
you know that that a lot of people have
complained that there's no there's no
Muslim Luther to set about a more
liberal form of of Islam and voix argued
that maybe the Muslim Luther is living
among us and his name is Osama bin Laden
and the reason for that is actually
quite quite evident once you think about
it you know the Protestant Reformation
was not a liberal revolution
John Calvin ran a very authoritarian
very intolerant City in Geneva and
people the Protestant Prince's in the
you know in in in Central Europe were
not fighting for pluralism they were
fighting to impose their particular
brand of Christianity on everybody else
but it did create the grounds for modern
individualism because Protestantism
separated belief from actual practice
and made it something internal and laws
argument is that in a way that's what's
happening in the Muslim diaspora if
you're a Muslim in Britain surrounding
society does not endorse your
religiosity and it has to become
something internal and so maybe that
plus another hundred years of conflict
in the Muslim world will lead to similar
conclusions has happened at the end of
the you know early modern period in
Europe but that's that's really
long-term thinking Robin has a question
where's Robin right here the other part
of your books title is and the last man
right and you described the end of
history as being populated by these sort
of sublimated pallid men without chests
all lawyers and bureaucrats as your
review changed as Myrna D have to be
that way well you know the end of
history the the fella that wrote about
this most cogently was Alexander Coe
Jeff was a Russian French philosopher
that did this very influential seminar
in Paris in the 1930s and 40s and of
course his view which I would agree with
was that the end of history is really
represented not by America but by the
European
Union and then he went on to become a
bureaucrat in the European Union and I
think actually the European Union today
represents you know the end state at the
end of history much more than the United
States I'm Americans you know we're
actually quite militaristic we love
fourth of July parades and we like our
army and we launch Wars and do all sorts
of things that last men really don't do
whereas Europeans actually you know
believe that they're in this post
national period where the big problem is
sovereignty and national selfishness and
that they're creating this yeah this
home for the last man called the
European Constitution where you get
beyond all of that stuff so the San
Francisco you may know is planning to
join the European Union
Schwarzenegger is making the connection
[Applause]
you spoke about you know France taking
500 years to do something and and
Singapore and Dubai have been attempting
the same thing in much shorter time Eric
has the question when that happens to
places like Singapore and Dubai have a
long-term effect on neighboring regions
particularly with respect to groups
resistant to modernization in those
regions sometimes yes sometimes no I
think that sometimes they serve as
positive examples Taiwan for example I
think was extremely important in
changing the thinking of the Chinese
Communist leadership because they saw a
Chinese society just across the Taiwan
Straits that was growing like crazy
because it had a market economy and you
know I think they drew some lessons for
that but you know on the other hand
modernization produces all of these
complex effects it's very socially
disruptive and so there are other places
they could be destabilized by very rapid
modernization so it's interesting there
is Taiwan kept much more of the
traditional Chinese culture herb shops
and things like that then mainland China
did and so part another part that seemed
to go across the the Straits was some of
the traditional Chinese practices yeah
well of course I mean you had communism
intervening in China which you know went
after Confucianism and the foul
and you know many aspects of traditional
Chinese cultures so that may be part of
the you know explanation of course a
couple of political ones I know you
don't mind cuz you had a whole ravening
group of communists in New Hampshire or
somewhere else going after you Marxist
sorry we don't have communists anymore
except in Cuba this one's from John
Rhenish what do you think of the project
for a new American Century which you
endorsed back in 2000 and since then
it's been pretty thick in the u.s.
foreign policy yeah well I don't know I
I find it very amusing all these
conspiracy theories built around the
project for the new American Century
because this was basically Bill Kristol
in a fax machine and every time you know
every time he thought something ought to
be done he'd sent a fax around to all of
his friends including me and say well
would you be willing to sign this letter
and so and so on a couple of occasions I
signed the letter and you know I don't
think that as an organization it
represented anything more than that now
underlying that were all sorts of
networks of people that had worked
together in different administrations
and you know with common educational
that I mean you know Bill Kristol is
actually I inherited his apartment in
Cambridge because we were classmates in
graduate school you know in the Harvard
government department so you know so you
have all these social ties that go back
but they're you know that organization
in and of itself I don't think was was
important since then you started a
magazine you want to see a little bit
about that
oh free advertising all right I started
a I started a new magazine called the
American interest I my article the end
of history had originally been published
in a magazine called the national
interest which went under new management
about three years ago that I didn't like
and so I left that and it seemed to me
that you know we in the late 1940s
centrism and bipartisanship were really
very popular and then we entered this
30-year period where it was just not
cool to be centrist you know
and everybody was pushing the envelope
on both ends of the political spectrum
mostly on the right but then you know on
the left and in response to that and you
could always get airtime for yourself by
trumping and saying something more
outrageous than last part I mean and
culture is now you know the absolute
queen bee of all this all of this stuff
but I think that you know that period is
over now because I think that if you
don't get back to some kind of
reasonable discussion that doesn't begin
from your political label but begins
with actually the problem that you have
to solve then you know you're not going
to get anywhere as a as a democracy so
the American interest was founded with
that in mind the other thing about it is
that it relates to this business about
America in the world because when we
started the magazine a lot of people
would say you know I just don't
understand what the United States is
right now and that wasn't just non
Americans saying that I mean I think a
lot of Americans can't figure out
exactly what's going on in the country
and so the magazine was designed both to
promote that kind of reasonable
political discussion but also to try to
explain the United States to everybody
else and to try to reconnect the u.s.
with with the rest of the world
okay one more partisan question this one
from Diane Pfeiffer two words scooter -
Libby
explanation as I understand you were an
advisory committee member or something
in support of him and yeah old friend
I'll come clean you know I I worked for
Paul Wolfowitz on two occasions in the
arms Control Agency in the mid-1970s and
then where I met scooter was when I
worked for him on the policy planning
staff in the early 1980s in the White
House and so I've been a friend of
scooters for the last you know what you
count the years since 1981 and and then
he went on to do the things that he did
and then he got into trouble and he
called me up and said
would you be on my whatever it is you
know committee a legal defense committee
and I said of course you know an old
friend of mine and it's quite
independent of my you know at this point
I had already written my last book
America at the crossroads in which I
explained why I was bailing out of this
hole
you know neocon way of looking at the
world but you know that doesn't may mean
that you're not a friend of you-know-who
you're a friend of so that's the only
explanation let's see a little bit about
your book at the crossroads is in the in
the outside the theater and I recommend
it just say a little bit about what your
critique of neo-cons came to be and
maybe where it is this very minute yeah
well that'll trigger a whole new tape
here I'll give you the three-minute
version of it sure what other stuff here
no I mean part of the reason I wrote
that book was that I did not think that
you know neoconservatism goes all the
way back to City College in the nineteen
late 1930s and all of these very radical
groups some of them Trotskyite and some
of them Stalinist that inhabited the
alcoves of the cafeteria there and they
all you know there were people like
Irving how Irving Kristol Daniel Patrick
Moynihan Nathan glazier Daniel Belle's
Seymour Martin Lipset people that became
absolute Giants as academics and as
public intellectuals in the next
generation and I thought that it was too
bad that a movement with this kind of
pedigree was being associated with
advocacy of the Iraq war because there
were other principles that they had
talked about that I think would not have
necessarily led to that among which were
a very great cautiousness about social
engineering the Irving Kristol magazine
the Public Interest was all about the
potentially negative effects of social
engineering when it came to American
domestic social policy and it just
struck me that a group of people with
that kind of pedigree would then
want to engage in one of the biggest
social engineering projects you could
imagine in in the Middle East biotech
now sometimes you sound a little bit
like Bill joy the the democratization of
weapons of mass destruction
biotechnology that may be coming in to
alter human nature itself and moving
into speed faster than you think the
political process can keep up I want to
see a little more about that yeah I I
don't see foresee inevitable doom here
because in the past our institutions
really have have adjusted to take
account of these new technologies it's
always you know Debra spar wrote this
book called ruling the waves a few years
ago where she actually looked at radio
and television and a whole bunch of
technological innovations and you know
first few years saying oh it's
completely unregulated entity they
figure out how to regulate it and then
it comes under you know greater control
and so I expect that process to continue
but I think that there are going to be
some you know difficult dimensions this
particularly in biotechnology because so
many of the things that troubled me
about it are also the things that are
great that make it good you know the the
fact that it's therapeutic means that
it's an undoubtedly good thing to
promote but the same drug that can be
used for therapeutic purposes can be
used for enhancement purposes in ways
that you know you might find or one
might find ethically questionable and so
I think as a has a problem of political
control it's it's you know it's a tough
one but but I'm not you know necessarily
a pessimist about this even in the case
of nuclear weapons I think that you know
we we we created this miracle I mean the
non-proliferation regime if you look at
the writing on the bomb in the period
right after 1945 people were predicting
that there would be nuclear wars and
50/60 nuclear states within a generation
and you know that simply didn't come to
pass we got close a couple times close
there's been three talks in this series
talking about the singularity the idea
of accelerating technology not only
getting ahead of the political process
but basically getting ahead of history
history and everything else so that one
can't know what's coming next
reycarts well gave the full story on
that Bruce Sterling and mocked it and
Vernor Vinge II came here and gave three
scenarios of how he thought it might not
happen but he still thought it probably
would happen now Roger Smith who's here
raised the question Bruce Sterling sees
a threat that human cognitive in
cognition will become industrialized by
hyper acceleration of Technology leading
to their version of the end of history
which is the singularity I don't have an
opinion about that I mean wow
this is your stuff yeah yeah I know that
that's the Christian rapture only you
know modernized you know I am not
convinced that the that the story of
ever accelerating technological change
at least as it plays out in society is
necessarily one that I accept this is
one comparison that I have asked my
students to think a lot about if you
compare the nature of American society
between the years 1850 and 1900 and
between the years 1950 and 2000 which of
those produced greater changes in the
way that Americans lived and I think
without question it was that earlier
period 1850 majority of Americans lived
on farms and isolated places without
good national communication by the year
1900 they were living in cities in
industrialized circumstances mass
education all sorts of you know really
important social changes brought about
by essentially industrialization if you
look at you know between 1950 and 2000
you know of course there's the internet
and information technology
which has had a big impact but we're
still living in a carbon-based you know
set of energy technologies many other
things are we have more of but in many
respects the you know in rise of you
know female empowerment
you know diversity a lot of other big
social changes but in many respects I'm
not sure that those collectively were as
great as the ones experienced a century
before and so I guess hmm so you
essentially do we could have a
singularity and barely notice or it you
know it could be that the social
response to this acceleration is
equilibrating mechanisms that exist on a
whole variety of different levels that
tend to push back against you know
whatever you know whatever change is
taking place but me raises cell phone
question in this context it's when you
go to Japan you'll see japanese
schoolgirls pushing the edge of the
possibilities what you can do with a
cell phone here comes the iPhone it's
going to push another set of
possibilities and when you got up happen
again II probably pretty far in the bush
you're gonna see folks with cell phones
and you know the numbers we're hearing
now is that about three billion people
have cell phone connectivity in the
developing world you can get a cell
phone or or access to a cell phone for
ten dollars oh and everybody's using it
and it's a thing which cuts right
through all of this poverty stuff all
this failed state stuff a whole lot of
the things which you've laid out as kind
of the defining forces here
one question I guess I would put to you
now and then maybe you would be fun to
do it again after your trip where do you
think cell phone plays into your story
of the coming of liberal democracy the
cell phone and other information
technologies of the past generation have
broadly been good for liberal democracy
because I think broadly speaking they
tend to defuse power rather than to
constant I think the you know the steel
and iron and coal age was probably bad
for democracy because
economies of scale tended to centralize
power and so forth so on that kind of
very abstract level I think that's the
case but as I understand the idea of a
singularity you have one set of
technological developments that then
produce results that are really not
linear and and and very unanticipated
and so forth and I would be astonished
if the cell phone revolution created a a
real state in Papua New Guinea in 25
years or solved the poverty problem in
Africa there are certain dimensions of
those problems that I think that or
maybe technology we don't know about you
know could could address but you know my
understanding of you know the sources of
development is that it is so complex and
it is so much based on an interlocking
of a lot of different factors that there
are very few times when you just you
know turn one knob and then you know the
whole switchboard lights up now that's
fair but we should honor the ok well
this being a Royce one more question
this one's from Kevin Kelly after
universal values are reached for most of
the world what's next well
there's actually a part of this that I
think is is here and now which is really
in a way the problem of the last man
that even in well in in in modern
liberal democracies we have a very thin
moral community that's you know where
Sir allistic and tolerant we do not
impose very strong opinions about good
and evil on people that live in our
societies and for the most part this is
not adequate for a lot of people that
they don't want to just be recognized as
equal free and equal human beings equal
to every other human being on the earth
they want to be québécois or they want
to be you know women or members of
indigenous community or Ukrainian or
some other source of communal identity
that is not universal but that does have
stronger values or is bound by you know
something tighter than then just
citizens in a impersonal democracy and
this is why identity politics has I
think become so important in all
developed societies and in and there's
some versions of identity politics that
then actually corrode the basis of
liberal democracy itself there they're
facing this problem in Europe already if
a Muslim family wants to force their
daughter to marry somebody back in
Morocco and she doesn't want to do it
right what does the state do about that
in terms of you know do you enforce her
rights as a as a free citizen or do you
defer to the community's interest and
there's just a whole series of problems
that we are living with now because of
this tension between group rights and
individual rights as you'll see a trend
well obviously for a long period from
the 60s up until the past decade the
trend was towards multiculturalism and
towards
the acceptance of group identities
increasingly I think what's interesting
in Europe right now is that there's been
an absolute revolt against us because of
the violence that you've seen in Holland
and Britain and elsewhere and in fact
the Dutch are kind of at the extreme of
this because they not only recognize
groups I mean they you know Protestants
and Catholics and socialists are all
organized with their own political
parties schools trade unions newspapers
I went and when the Muslims showed up
they just said okay you can have your
own pillar which is a you know it's kind
of the ultimate version of this identity
politics it but you know the problem was
that it turned out that people in the
Muslim pillar were not actually feeling
like they were part of Dutch society and
so there's been this big backlash
against against that and towards the
feeling that you have to have a broader
more inclusive national identity and so
we'll see where we go with this because
well it see this for a minute because it
does really challenge your thesis in a
sense you were saying European Union is
the model yeah and but European Union is
having more of an identity politics
that's right issues in militaristic
jingoistic yes this is the other another
way in which I could be falsified is if
you get backlash movements for example
against immigration in Europe that
undermine the liberal basis of European
society which i think is conceivable I
wouldn't bet on it it's conceivable yeah
I mean my book you'll write then as well
history is back on well you know this is
really no I mean I would say that
Huntington then would be right I mean
this is this is a retreat mm-hm you know
this is the basic difference between us
he believes that these communal
identities are primary and that you're
never going to get beyond them and that
liberal institutions and globalization
whatever forces for integration they
represent are not strong enough to melt
this kind of communal glue and I believe
that the integrating forces are strong
enough that the defeat
of them by these primordial attachments
is not given and that's you know that's
the essence of the dispute between us
that's clear do you think we'll know by
2050 what which way it's going I would
hope a lot sooner than that because I
think a lot of this stuff is going to
hit a crisis you know much sooner than
than 20 facetious a little more European
goes in crisis because of migrants yeah
you're already seeing a lot of that and
backlash politics you're seeing that in
in a different form in in in this
country as well and so I do think this
was actually going to play out in the
next decade and we don't have to wait
till 2050 to see okay well thank you
very much all right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]